while kelly is a great person and an
incredible artist and a great talk show
host
she is hands down
the worst coach we've ever had on the
voice
if there's one thing we know about blake
shelton it's that he loves giving his
fellow coaches on the voice a hard time
i would like to think so
on thursday the 45 year old country
singer appeared on the tonight show
starring jimmy fallon when the two got
to talking about the hit nbc competition
show weirdly i think you might win it
again this year
do you really think that honestly you
think that you said it do you really
think that
because i feel like you were really
building me up there and i was waiting
for
because you and i don't really trust
each other yeah and so i was waiting for
you to for the backhand to come in but
you really do mean that no i think
kelly's gonna win this year but i just
you're on the show tonight so i figured
well you know but i i do like uh
i like kelly's bands pretty good jimmy
of course is referring to the group girl
named tom who is on kelly clarkson's
team
[Music]
and blake who is the only remaining
original voice coach admitted that the
band is pretty good but he also said
this the only thing i worry about
with that particular group is they're on
kelly's team she is hands down the worst
coach we've ever had on the voice and
when the late night tv host challenged
him on that he revised his statement
out of everyone you've ever had you've
met yeah more than adam
she is the second worst coach that we
have ever had
on this on this show for sure
without question
of course the atom they're referring to
is adam levine who left his big red
chair after season 16. you want a trend
on twitter that's what this is all about
i'll see i see your motive i want to see
you cry
make blake cry but blake wasn't only
taking playful shots at kelly and adam
he also poked fun at new coach ariana
grande who has gotten a little emotional
this season especially when she has to
send one of her contestants home
i
adore you both so much
it felt so consistently phenomenal uh
you know what she's a little shaky
honestly she's
uh she's having a tough time uh you know
emotionally with this thing she's
it's like i i have to tell her after
every episode if she has somebody go
home it's like you know they didn't
they didn't send them to like the
alligator
pit or something ariana you know they're
gonna do fine they're gonna do well
i don't think
people see her cry on tv but
you can't imagine when the camera goes
off i feel so privileged to work with
you and to spend this time with people
we love you
e.t recently caught up with blake and
ari and the god is a woman singer opened
up about her first season on the show
admitting that sometimes her emotions do
get the best of her i've been emotional
i think it's my first season i think
there's so much to learn there's so much
amazing talent and you know you never
want to
have someone feel like just because this
moment in the context of this
competition in this exact second
has anything to do with their talent and
how amazing they are you know um
yeah but everyone's amazing and it's
definitely emotional and especially when
blake's drink runs out he gets very
emotional cranky i get cranky the only
time as for blake he says he's a little
more jaded and only gets sad for one
very specific not sad reason
it's only been emotional for me yes not
for him i don't think i've cried one
time my drink didn't work
my drink did get empty one time halfway
through an audition and there was like
no way to excuse myself it made me sad
but you've actually been emotional for
the right reasons